الى هذا الخبر العاجل نقلا عن مراسل
الجزيره فان الشرطه الفرنسيه تعتقل شخصا
هاجم بسلاح الابيض عدد من الاشخاص وذلك في
محطه اللي هي القطارات الشماليه العاصمه
باريس وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه نقلت عن
الشرطه الفرنسيه وقالت بان هناك جرحى اذا
في عمليه
الطعن وقعت تحديدا في محطه قطارات
جارجونار بالعاصمه باريس مسؤول فرنسي نقله
دائما عن وكاله الانباء الفرنسيه قال بان
حركه المرور تعطلت في محطه جار جونور في
باريس وذلك هجوم الشخص كان يحمل سكينا على
عده اشخاص ينضم اليها نور الدين بوزيان
مراسله جزيره من باريس مرحبا نور الدين هل
لديك تفاصيل او فعل ما وقع
محمد اولا وزير الداخليه اعلن بانه سيتوجه
الى المحطه التي كانت مسرحا لهذه العمليه
بعد نصف ساعه سيكون هناك وقال بانه سيذهب
لتقديم الشكر لرجال الامن وكانت تغريده
سابقه للوزير تحدث عن او اكدت وقوع الهجوم
وتحدث الوزير عن
اثنى على السرعه التي تدخل بها رجال الامن
الجديد محمد وان احد رجال الامن يعمل في
شرطه الحدود يكون قد اصيب بتروح ولكن هذه
الجروح وصفت من قبل الاجهزه الامنيه بانها
جروح خفيفه حتى هذه اللحظه لا نعرف بدقه
عدد الاشخاص الذين اصيبوا مذكر بان وسائل
الاعلام الفرنسيه وايضا وزير الداخليه
كانت تحدث عن اصابه عدد من الاشخاص دون ان
يحدد العدد بدقه المحطه كما تعلم محمد هي
اكبر محطات القطارات هنا في باريس ومنها
تتوجه
القطارات وتاتي من داخل والى خارج باريس
والمدن الكبرى وخاصه باتجاه الشمال وايضا
هي محطه تنطلق منها قطارات باتجاه هولندا
وبلجيكا
وبريطانيا ولحد هذه اللحظه ايضا حسب
القنوات الفرنسيه المحليه فان المهاجم
يكون قد تلفظ بكلمات الله اكبر هذا الخبر
او هذه الشهاده لا نستطيع ان اعتيد هذه
حتى هذه
نور الدين
صوره هي فعليه ثابته لمحطه القطارات قاره
جينار همم هي اول سوره هذه الينا من
الواضح ان هناك طوقا امنيا فرضته اذا
القوه الامنيه هناك تظهر الصوره مثل ما هو
واضح عدد من رجال الشرطه
وتبقى هذه الصوره الاوليه المتوفره حاليا
همم في حين الاصول ربما صور فيديو توضح
همم ما الذي يحدث حاليا في تلك المحطه
خاصه وانه تم القاء القبض على من قام بهذه
العمليه عمليه الطعن ليس كذلك نرتي
نعم في التفاصيل حول كيف تم القاء القبض
على الجاني اطلق عليه النار ويكون قد اصيب
باسبات خفيفه همم طبعا السوق الامني همم
سيتم تخفيفه بعد ساعه نظرا لان الاجهزه
الامنيه ستقوم وتستكمل اجراءات تحري
والبحث وبعد ذلك ليس من مصلحه السلطات ان
تبقي على هذه المحطه مقفله ساعات كثيره
لانها محطه اساسيه
وكبيره جدا وذكر بان التوقيت هذا الهجوم
جاء في وقت يشهد فيها ويشهد في هذه المحطه
في باب كبير همم تدفق عدد كبير من
المسافرين القادمين الى باريس او هذا
المغادرين وفي جميع الحالات لحد هذه
اللحظه اعود واكرر باننا في انتظار تفاصيل
اخرى خاصه من الاجهزه الامنيه لان وزير
الداخليه لحد الان اكتفى بتغريده لم يقل
فيها الشيء الكثير باستثناء انه شكر قوه
الامن على رده فعلها الجريئه والفعاله حسب
ما ورد في تغريده وزير الداخليه محمد شكرا
ما جزيلا لك نور الدين بوزيا مراسل
الجزيره كنت معي من باريس بالتاكيد ساعود
اليك خلال هذه النشره او في الخدمات
الاخباريه المقبله حاله توفر معلومات اكثر
عن ما حدث اذا في محطه القطارات جار في
العاصمه